(Narrator) See those glowing specs of light?
Yeah
(Narrator) Those are soul shards
Okay
(Narrator) Fragments of spirit, scattered through the whole of this little maze
(Narrator) Gather them all, and the first puzzle piece will be revealed
Yes ma'am
(Narrator) One more thing
Yeah?
(Narrator) You are not alone
Oh no
(Narrator) There's a monster in here
(Narrator) A little something I plugged from your worst nightmares
Noooo!
(Narrator) And it's looking for you
Oh no!
(Narrator) This is the point...
Okay
(Narrator) ...where you start running for your life
Oh, okay
Oh, oh what is that?
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Dark Deception I think is the name of the game
And apparently, this is a lot like Pac-Man
Which is wierd 'cause I just played an impossible game of Pac-Man earlier
There's something in here
I can hear it
I can hear you
Ahhh ffffff ahahaaha
Oh my god
Ahahaha
It's a monkey
It's a murder monkey
A murder monkey is after me
Oh my god, that's a lot of shards
wooo they give you an early start
[BABBLING]
That'll... that'll wake you up better than coffee
Ok so, I got my little uh, monkey friend coming at me
uhuh uki aka don't kill me, please
don't murder me in the face
that'd be much appreciated if you didn't
where is he? I hear him
I got a little mini-map
I barely had time to register what was going on
before I was thrust sudussly into the
Hi. Uhh he found me
Hahaha, wait a minute hang on
aah! Okay, he's a little bit closer than I thou...
AAH! There's two! AAAH!
(Narrator) Monkey kill. Monkey kill.
Monkey kill? Jeez... Oh... Oh oh, it is like Pac...
Oh, is that my blood on the wall? Probably not
(Narrator) You gahtered half of the shards
I did?
(Narrator) I'm impressed
Good, thank you, lady
Who is apparently a...
What? What'd you say?
What'd you say? Did you say something about me?
Say som' about my momma?
What? Who? Oh, hi!
You're a bit of a swishy swashy with these swordy wordies
Ahh, I need to go this way
Ahh, I try to watch my minimap and also listening to where they are
But it's hard to listen when i'm yelling in my own ear
It's a monkey
AAH! Whadaswe!
Oh, okay
Good guy
Blach, blach
Get away from me, monkey, you monkey douche
That's really cool, the way they round the corners
That's really elegant
That's really cool
And really disturbing
And so cool
And so creepy
And so cute
Not cute
Okay, nevermind, going this way
AAH! Whaswa aha
I don't know what I expect..aah okay
That's bad
Aaah, hi
Aaaha
Sorry, you startled me
I apologize
For anyone who ehh
ahh gwdgasaaah
Aah! Fuck, god damn it
Uuh
Hi, hello friend, how are you doing over there?
Aah, no you back up, you son of a biiitch
Uuuuurgh, I don't wanna play
I don't wanna play today
Oh, oh you creepy fudge
[Narrator] He's right behind you
I know he's behind me, lady, thank you very much,
I'm very well aware of where he is
Hiiiii
Ughhhh
Nieghh
Okey dokey
This's good, this's good, I like this
This's very good
This is my favourite thing, actually
Ahh gsch, ahhoh
He's right behind...AAH!
Uuuugh...
Who's a little monkey? Whos a litt...ughughughAAHGHA!
Ohhh... god damn it
I shouldn't be messing with the monkeys, but they're just so fun to mess with
Monkeyyyy
Monkey see?
Mon...ughughnooo
(Narrator) Keep going
Keep going? I am going. I'm nearly there
They're nearly at my butt.
They're trying to stab me in my patuty
Oh hello, AAH!
I don't know, what I was trying to do there
I really don't know
[BLOB SOUNDS]
Ahh, where are you?
[MORE BLOB SOUNDS]
I'm going around the outer perimeter first, because that's a more grecious method of which way I can do this
Apparently, something around that
Oh, hi!
Wait a minute I need to go there
Not today, not yet
I need to go
[GIBBERISH]
I'm gonna do it
That old lady ain't got nothing on me
So where am I going, okay, let's go this way
Playin' it out,
I hear him
Where is...?
[SCREAMING]
What the hell?
"Press 'e' to interact"?
what does that even mean?
[DOOR SOUNDS]
What, why?
Why can I do that? Let me out!
There are murder monkeys after me
I need to actually get...
(Narrator) He's right behind you
Shut up
You're lying
He's not right behind me
Aah! He's right behind me!
Uhhgh
AAAH! NO!
Aaaagh... son of a bitch
Oh, that's a painting of the monkeys,
look at them, they're so adorable
Hey, that looks just like you!
I'm gonna run away now
[LITTLE GIRL SOUNDS]
Aah! FFuu...okay not going that way
Hi, uhm I needed to go there, so if you could not be a son of a bitch,
that'd be delightful
Aah! Ooohkay
Aooohkay
Nonononononononoo
What's with this monkey portal?
Why is there a monkey portal?
(Narrator) Run, run!
I am running you douche
Come on, come on big boy
Waah big boy
That's what you are
That's right
That's right, get it right, get it tight
Oooh I'm about to get it
Oh no, oh what's that?
Oh what's that over there?
Oh I...
Why isn't it over?
WHY IS IT NOT OVER?
AAH! WHY IS IT NOT OVER?
What did...? AAAH!
Uhhkay...
Monkeys, murder monkeys
Murder mu...
oh, there's a
Oh, well if it's that all I need then...
Ohh, what's that? I'm about to get the blue
Whatya doin'?
Not at all
awww, couldn't get it
[LAUGHING]
That was really fun
That was surprisingly really fun
I'm gonna be perfectly honest, is there any more to that?
Aww man...
Aww I thought there was gonna be more
I'm gonna mess with the murder monkeys just a little bit more
Hello! Monkey see, monkey don't kill me please
Ohh monkey! Hello!
Hello!
Oh, you such a big boy, ain't ya?
You such...
eww you're a little too close to me
You such big boy, ain't ya?
That's really gotta good animanations,
I gotta admit
That's an elegant monkey
Eww, aah, too close!
Very too close!
Stranger danger!
Oww
Monkey, hiii, heyy
I really do wonder if one of these doors does open
Hello, friend
Oh, hello
Aah! Hello friend
Three friends
Now, there's too many friends
I don't need that many friends
Come here, come on
[KISSING SOUNDS]
Aah!
They was behind me
Hello? Hii!
Okay, bye
Whatcha doin'? Whatcha doin' there?
Whatcha doin' there?
Hi ya'll, hi ya'll
What's going on, little buddy?
What's [GIBBERISH]
Monkey
bugabugabuga
bugabugabugabug
Ahh ehh hi
bugabugabuga
Boop! Got 'em all
I'm the winner
Still don't know what that big old oooh...
Okayy! Here we go, I beat it twice now
That wasn't bad, that was acutally really fun
I'm actually quite surprised
That was an innovative mechanic I guess
if you can call Pac-Man innovative
But either way, that was lot of fun
You can check the description down below
Let me know what you think of this,
and I think this is just a demo so,
a full version may be coming out in the future
either way, this was really cool, so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotations for more videos that I've done
And as always:
I will see YOU, in the next video
Bye bye
[OUTRO MUSIC]